Good morning, YouTube.
So, I know that you flocked this channel
because I am such a sunny and optimistic
person. I bring cheer in a world of
gloom.
You may face some difficulties in your
life, but you know that when you watch
my videos, I I'm going to tell you how
great the world is. Unfortunately,
today um it's all going to be doom and
gloom. I'm going to talk about how the
western world
um is going to collapse and there's
nothing anyone can do about it.
So, let me start with a concrete
example. I live in Canada and um these
past few years I've just seen Canadian
society um get worse and worse. A lot of
the issue uh is this relentless
immigration these past five years.
Millions of people have come into this
country seeking a better life.
Unfortunately, they congregate in only a
few cities where there are economic
opportunities.
And as a result, housing prices have
gone up, inflation
has gone up, cost of living has gone up,
but wages have been stagnant or
depressed because of the surge in cheap
labor. And in Toronto, if you're not
making at least $100,000
uh a year, it's very hard to get by. And
quite frankly, most are not making that
kind of money and most are struggling.
So, crime has gone up, homelessness has
gone up, drug addiction has gone up. Um,
it's a very dire situation in Canada.
Now, it's easy to blame the immigrants
and um I don't think the reason
um are the immigrants. I myself am
immigrant. So,
um maybe I'm biased, but I will say that
um we came over in about 1983
and my dad was a high school teacher in
a village in Canada. Uh sorry, we were
my my dad was a high high school teacher
in our village back in China. And we
were really thankful for opportunity to
come to Canada and we felt really
blessed because life back in China was
just terrible. Um it's really hard for
anyone today to imagine the poverty in
China back then during the cult
revolution. But let me give you a
concrete example. 15 years ago, my dad
came to visit me in Beijing when I was
working as a high school administrator
and he bought an entire duffel bag,
a huge duffel bag of toilet rolls, 24 uh
toilet rolls. And the reason why is
toilet paper was considered the ultimate
luxury back in our village um
during the cult revolution. And so maybe
he wanted to give these toilet rolls to
all the all his relatives and show
everyone that he's made it in can in
Canada. Well, the problem was that um he
had a very hard life in Canada as most
recent immigrants do.
He was a dishwasher for his entire life.
And as a dishwasher working in
restaurants and bars, he encountered a
lot of racism and humiliation. So, let
me give you a example. Um, one day my
dad and I went to a supermarket to buy
some butter. We couldn't find the butter
because the supermarket was just huge.
So my dad,
she saw a clerk wearing his uniform, his
um white uniform. And my dad asked him,
"Sorry, sir. Do you know where the
butter is?" Okay. I mean, his English
isn't that great though, but it was
pretty easy to understand what my dad
wanted. The store clerk looks at him
briefly and says, "Sorry, I don't work
here." Okay, so that's a sort of
humiliation that my dad face every day.
as a new immigrant in Canada who didn't
have any status and whose English wasn't
very good. Um, we were very poor in
Canada. We could have easily qualified
for welfare, but we didn't we didn't
apply for welfare because we didn't know
welfare existed.
Um, I remember late at night my dad
would sneak out across the street and
pick up some sofas or chairs that the
neighbors had discarded and they would
become our furniture.
My dad cut my hair. Um, so believe it or
not, but when I was younger, my hair uh
was actually worse than it is today. And
so the kids made fun of me. Um, I had
bad hair, uh, uneven hair. My mom bought
me clothes from bargain outlets, so they
were crappy clothes. They weren't Nike
or Adidas that that the other kids were
wearing, and I smell bad. So,
understandably, the um, other kids
teased me. I was very unpopular. So, I
focused on school. I focused on uh,
getting out of poverty. And through hard
work, I went to Yale University on a
full scholarship. And that opened new
doors, new vesters for me. And so I I
really achieved the Canadian dream. And
um if it weren't for Canada, if it
weren't for Yale, I wouldn't be able to
make YouTube videos. Um so I'm very
thankful uh for Canada and for
um for Yale. So, um, again, we're really
thankful for the opportunity to come and
but the reality is there's just too many
immigrants coming into
uh this country. And what that's and
what's really happening is even though
you may have some short-term economic
GDP burst,
ultimately you're degrading the social
capital trust and cohesion of Canada.
Ultimately,
um the Canadian identity has always been
fragile and all this massive influx of
immigrants is making the identity much
more fragile which is in the long term
going to affect
uh Canada's capacity to work together to
innovate to be resilient uh to be
cohesive as a society. Um
right now
a quarter 25% of Canadians are um
foreignb born first generation
immigrants like myself. So if there if
there were ever a referendum
and um Canadians could choose whether or
not to join the United States
voluntarily,
most of these um immigrants would
immediately say, "Let's join the United
States because there are more economic
opportunities."
Um so in the long term, I don't see
Canada staying together. I think Canada
will ultimately be be dismembered by the
United States and be absorbed into the
American Empire in the next 20, 30
years. I I don't think Canada right now
can be a sustainable uh nation.
Now, it's really easy to blame
immigrants for all of this, and most
Canadians do, in fact, blame immigrants
because that's what uh they encounter
every day. They encounter immigrants not
being able to speak English, not
following the rules, cutting in line. Uh
they they they watch the news and see
immigrants uh committing crimes.
They see immigrants um rich immigrants
buying up these expensive property and
making life miserable for everyone. So
it's really easy to blame the
immigrants, but ultimately we need to
understand why this immigration is
happening. And it's happening because of
the baby boomers.
The baby boomers want three things. They
want um their pensions to be paid. They
want quality free health care. And they
want the property prices to go up.
Basically, they want the Canadian
economy to keep on growing and growing
and growing regardless of the uh
consequences.
Now, in order for the economy to grow,
there are three main mechanisms to
accomplish this. Uh the first mechanism
is to exploit resources because Canada
really is the wealthiest country in the
world. It has abundant almost infinite
uh resources especially fresh water
which is what the world is going to need
in the next hundred years. So Canada is
extremely wealthy place and it can
choose to exploit and export a lot of
these resources. Okay, that's the first
solution. The second solution uh which
is much sustainable is to unleash the
entrepreneurial energy of the Canadian
people uh to encourage uh more um
entrepreneurship more and more
privatization to reduce the regulatory
state uh to reduce the red tape. Okay,
that's the second solution. The third
solution is um
immigration. Let's let in more
immigrants. Let's let in the rich
immigrants to uh pour cash into the
economy. Let's let in poor immigrants so
that they work as slave labor for
Canadian corporations.
So of these three solutions, the Can
government went with the third solution,
increase immigration. Now, a lot of
people out there believe that this is a
conspiracy that there's this global
international conspiracy out there to
dilute national identity um to destroy
the idea of the nation state to reduce
uh the white gene pool. Um this is all a
world economic forum white replacement
theory uh conspiracy spearheaded by the
Jews.
And quite honestly, if the people in
charge were this smart, were this well
organized, the world wouldn't be in the
mess that it is today. Um, you'd be
surprised by how idiotic, by how uh
incompetent the people in charge are.
So, let me explain to you why
immigration is increasing not just in
Canada, but also throughout the western
world. Okay? So to understand this we
need to understand the framework of the
Canadian Canadian nation. Why does
Canada exist and what does Canada do?
Well Canada has some certain um unique
characteristics. First of all it's a
vast nation with almost infinite wealth
uh surrounded by two oceans the Pacific
and the Atlantic. And so Canada does not
have like natural predators as they
would in Europe. Canadians grew up in a
time of relative peace, uh, safety, and
security.
Um, the problem though is that Canada
shares a border with the world's most
powerful
empire with with history's greatest
empire, uh, America.
And um so in order to prevent conflict
between Canada and United States, the
last major conflict between Canada and
United States was the war of 1812. To
prevent the conflict um there's almost
an implicit agreement between the people
of Canada and the people of America.
Canadians first and foremost are not
ambitious. If Canadians were ambitious
then uh Canada would be at war with
America and America would have absorbed
Canada into the American empire uh a
long time ago. So Canadians the first um
the core characteristic of the identity
is lack of ambition in order to maintain
peace and stability with uh America.
And if and if you're not ambitious, then
you're not going to industrialize, which
means that you're going to maintain and
safeguard the environment. You'll use
some of the environment, but you'll but
you'll make sure it's self-sustaining.
So, in other words, Canada is almost
like a resource bank for the American
Empire. Uh the American Empire when it
needs can always draw on the infinite
resources of Canada.
And so um because of its lack of
ambition, there are two main drivers of
the Canadian economy. The first, as I
said, is um resource exportation, but
sustainable limited resource
exploitation. But the main driver of the
Canadian economy is immigration.
Um Canada allows rich corrupt um
families to come to Canada to hide their
wealth. Canada also welcomes cheap uh
labor uh poor immigrants like my father
to come to Canada to do all the work so
that Canadians can enjoy their life on
uh drinking beer drinking molins a
terrible beer by the way um by the uh
cottage and because of this economic
framework three major religions have
developed in Canada to sustain this
economic framework. The first religion
is environmentalism. So can Canadians
love the environment. They believe it is
their duty, their inherent duty to
protect and love trees. Um that's the
first religion. Second religion is
multiculturalism.
Uh the belief that diversity is good
mainly because white people love ethnic
food. When white people think
multiculturalism, they think ethnic
restaurants, Mexican food, Chinatown. Uh
and so they love they love
multiculturalism.
But if immigrants um become politically
ambitious like the Indians, no, you
can't have that. Um so uh that's why
Indians are so derided in Canada because
the Indians are actually politically
active and effective. And if but hey, if
they didn't stick to making samosas
every day, Hadians would love them.
Um, so
in a multicultural society, what's
really important is to be an open
society and not have a distinct cultural
identity. Um, and this is and and this
has created a lot of problems in Canada.
It'll create further problems in Canada.
And the
um
um third third major religion is
bureaucraticism, right? Because if you
don't have your own ethnic identity, if
you don't have a core ambition, then you
need a regulatory state, a bureaucracy
in order to maintain everything
together. Um, you need people to tell
you what to do.
And Canadians
worship authority. Canadians are
extremely obedient. Canadian Canadians
um uh believe experts know everything.
Okay. So because of these three
religions um there are three distinct
characteristics about the can Canadian
individual. Okay. Um what are Canadians
really good at? Well the first thing is
Canadians are really good at following
the rules from birth. Canadians believe
that they must obey the rules. The worst
thing that can happen is if they break a
rule.
Second um thing that the Canadians
really are are are really good at um is
being polite uh to other people because
in a multicultural society you don't
don't want to offend everyone. Um but I
but I will say that I have noticed in my
most recent uh trip to back to Canada,
Canadians um are no longer so polite. um
they're much more passive aggressive
than before because of the dire economic
situation that Canada is in right now.
The third thing that Canadians are
really good at, in fact, probably the
best in the world at is being mediocre.
Okay, Canadians absolutely have no
ambition. In fact, they hate ambition. I
remember in high school because I was
poor and I wanted to go to Yale, I was
extremely focused on grades. And so my
teachers, the word they use for me is
ambitious. I'm an ambitious individual.
That's essentially a curse word in
Canada. But I will say this, Canada, I
mean, if you can just
conceptualize heaven on earth, it would
be Canada, right? Extreme wealth, um
extremely generous uh government
benefits. Uh no one will go will will go
poor, no one will starve in Canada.
Um no wars, just complete peace. It's
almost heaven on earth. And here is an
opportunity for people to achieve
udeimmonia, right? Udimmonia is is the
Greek term for flourishing. here in here
is opportunity for Canadians to
contribute intellectually to development
of humanity uh because they have the
resources, they have the time, uh they
have the security. No one no one else
does.
And so you would expect this tremendous
outpouring of human creativity in Canada
these past 50 years.
In reality, Canadians have for the past
50 years chosen to shut off their
brains. Okay? And Canada is an extremely
complacent nation. It's almost like
everyone's on V on um Prozac or
something. This is this is Prozac
Nation.
So, um Canadians are extremely mediocre.
Um,
I I think that
after Canada becomes dismember
dismembered and joins the American
Empire, maybe a generation afterwards,
Evans going to forget Canada ever
existed because Canada has made
absolutely no contribution to uh to the
world. Canada um doesn't really matter
in the world and Canadians are very
happy do not matter in the world.
So um so now we can understand if your
three religions are
um environmentalism, multiculturalism
and bureaucratism.
Well then there's only one solution for
you, right? Because you can't exploit
resources because of your religion of en
environmentalism. You can't encourage
entrepreneurship because of your
religion of aircraftism. Right? You
don't want to reduce the regulatory
state.
um you don't want to promote individual
initiative.
Um so the only solution available to you
is mass immigration.
Okay. Um and again a lot of it is driven
by the baby boomers. So now let me
explain to you why baby boomers suck.
And they suck for um three main reasons.
The first is that they're the most
selfish generation in human history.
Second is that they're going to be the
longest living generation in human
history. And the third is that um they
want to maintain the empire. All right?
So, let me go uh through each one by
one. Baby boomers are selfish. Everyone
knows this. Um they had the most
luxurious life. Um but but the problem
is that if you always lived a life of uh
comfort and security and prosperity, you
become a selfish individual because you
think you deserve all this. Okay. The
other thing is that the baby boomers
have a religion and it's an achievement.
It's an ethos of achievement and
accumulation. The more the better. The
bigger the better.
Uh, the more money I have, the better.
The longer I live, the better. I'm I
need to accumulate and accumulate and
achieve and achieve in order to signify
my value, my my worth and um their
greed, their selfishness is destroying
the environment, it's destroying the
economy and ultimately it's going to
kill their children. Okay, so that's the
first thing. Uh, baby MRS are extremely
selfish and that by itself is not really
a problem. The problem is they're not
dying. Um
um and I can understand why. Okay.
Because I because at home I I'm living
with my dad and my dad is in his early
80s and as I said previously he's had
this terrible life. Uh 10 years ago he
got diagnosed with Parkinson's. Five
years ago he had a bad fall while using
the um uh bathroom. and now he's
paralyzed. Um
um and we really fought 5 years ago.
That was it. Um he had he had a few
months to live, but he's still going.
And so he has Parkinson's. He's
basically paralyzed. Um and he's living
his best life.
All his life he's worked slave wages,
minimum wage, and now he's collecting a
very generous pension from the Canadian
government. It's free money for him.
He has access to the best health care.
Honestly, if we had to pay for the
health care, we couldn't afford it and
he he would have died five years ago.
But now, because it's all being paid by
the Cany government, um he he spent six
months at a really nice hospital with
his own room. Every day, a a physical
therapist comes to the house and helps
him regain some um some muscle control
um and does some cleaning for him.
And really um it's his best life and his
in his house. He has his own house and
because of all this immigration he's
seeing the property value go up. He's
seeing himself get getting wealthier and
wealthier. If you're a baby boomer who's
been taught that what matters is
achievement and accumulation.
Why would you give up now? Right? As
your life gets gets better and better.
Why would you give it up now? So even
though you know he's bedridden all the
time I see him cling to life. Um, and I
can understand why because he's been
through so much crap and now he can
really begin to enjoy himself. This is
really heaven on earth for him. So, he
doesn't want he doesn't want to die.
Okay? But it's not just him. It's the
entire generation of baby boomers,
millions and millions of them. And in
Canada, they're they're a quarter of the
population. So, they control all the
political power. They control all the
wealth. And therefore, they can dictate
government policy. I have a friend in
New York City, a very famous um person,
extremely wealthy, like tens of millions
of of dollars,
and she's 90 and she has Alzheimer's and
she can't walk mo most of the time she's
um sleeping. She's semicoma basically.
And I I thought, you know, any day now,
she could die. But I've been thinking
that for the past 10 years. And one day
I asked my cousin who's a doctor,
listen, if you're 90 years old and
you're senile, you have Alzheimer's, you
can't get out of bed, but you have
unlimited wealth, how long can modern
medicine keep you going? Like how long
can you survive? He has and she has like
four full-time caregivers to make sure
that you know she is taken care of. And
my cousin, the doctor said to me, she
can go on for another 20 years at least,
another 20 years at least. So these baby
boomers aren't dying. Okay, so the baby
boomers have captured all the wealth of
society. Um, and they refuse to share
any of it because of their achievement
ethos and they're not dying. So um, but
but then there's actually a much bigger
problem which is that baby boomers are
wedded to the idea of empire. Last year
I was in Brooklyn uh visiting some some
friends. I got invited to a uh party and
they and this party was full of China
experts. So apparently every China
expert in in the world is from Brooklyn.
So um after COVID when they were forced
out of China they had they all returned
to Brooklyn. And so I met all of them at
this uh party and I was talking to one
lady very very very wealthy comes from a
very powerful family and I uh and she
was a baby boomer and I um and I talked
I discussed with her we were talking
individually oneonone I was I I said to
her privately my fears about the
American u political system I said my
fear is that given the trajectory of
American foreign policy which which
which is like extremely non-existent. I
said there's a danger that America could
be fighting wars on three major fronts.
America could be fighting simultaneously
Russia, Iran, and China. And then she
looked at me and said, "That's fine.
We're America. We're in we're with the
indispensable nation. We can do this. We
can take on all three and defeat all
three. Does not matter." Okay, that's
the arrogance of empire. All right, so
let me give you an image of what empire
is. And for this image, I'm going to
draw on the play the bakai from Ubides.
If you have not read Ubupes, you must
read Eupites, one of the greatest
playwrights in human history. So he
wrote uh the play the Bakai about the
year um 400 uh BCE. This is this is like
um after the Pelipasian war when Athens
the Athenian Empire which had become
basically a mafia state basically
decided to go to war against the entire
world and thousands and thousands of the
young people died in these wars of
empire. And so uh Urbes wrote the Bakai
almost as a critique of empire. And so
the ending of the Bakai goes like this.
Um there's a religious festival in the
mountains and these women are all
drugged out. Okay? They're hallucinating
and as part of the religious festival
they sacrifice a man who's the king of
thieves uh pantheus.
And so what they do is they capture him.
They rip him apart. Okay? They
physically rip him apart. They rip up
the limbs. They rip up the legs. They
dismember him. And the person who rips
um off his head is actually his mother,
a gay.
And after she does this, she becomes
ecstatic. And she ticks the head and she
runs back to the city of thieves. And
she proclaims to the citizens, "Look at
what I've done." And she's holding
uh the head of her son Pentheus in her
right hand. And she's saying to
everyone, "This is a lion's head." You
see how brave, you see how powerful, you
see how virtuous I am for fighting a
lion and ripping his head off. And then
everyone looks at her a gas. They don't
believe that she that she can't see the
truth.
And so finally her father, Catmiss, um
has to tell her, "I gave that's not a
lion's head. That's a that's the head of
your son.
So that's what an empire is. Okay, if
you want to know what an empire is,
remember the image of a mother holding
the head of
her son
and proclaiming the world,
look how brave, powerful, and virtuous I
am.
An empire is a system where the old
sacrifice the young for their glory.
Okay, that's what an empire is. And
that's what the baby boomers want. They
grew up in a time of the Pax Americana.
They don't want to see it die in their
lifetimes. They rather burn down the
entire empire.
They rather sacrifice their own children
and their grandchildren than to lose
the idea of empire while they're alive.
Okay. So that's why the baby boomers
have
basically told the American government
to launch these wars around the world to
save the Pax Americana because that's
the system they grew up in. That's the
system they want to die in the Pax
Americana. the Anglo-American Empire.
They want to feel virtuous,
powerful, and strong.
Okay? And they don't care if they have
to burn down the world in order to do
so. And so the question then is what can
we do? Well, you think about it, there's
nothing we can do because, as I said,
the baby boomers are the most dominant
political group in the Western world.
They control the political system. They
control the financial system. They can
control the cultural system. They and
they're our parents. They're the people
um
we we love and honor and cherish. I I'm
not going to say to my father, "Hey,
Dad. Um you're paralyzed.
Um
your life doesn't have any meaning
anymore.
And maybe it's time for you to rest in
peace and and so that the
um
um rest of the world uh the young can
have their place.
So one metaphor that I think best
describes the world we live in is rat
utopia. Uh rat utopia are series of
experiments conducted by James B. Cahun
in the 60s and 70s and this was a time
of growing abundance in the world and
this this is the first time in human
history when we escaped scarcity the
promise of scarcity. So you want to to
um
look at what would happen if we looked
if we lived in a world of um abundance.
So they created these experiments, these
colonies where rats were allowed to live
in a world of abundance. There were no
predators. Uh there was unlimited water
and food. And what happened each time he
did this experiment and no matter how he
tweaked the experiment, the result was
the same. What happened was the social
hierarchy
uh that governed the rat colony
um collapse and Kahun calls this the
behavior sync and very quickly the rats
start to cannibalize each other. Um they
start to engage in all sorts of uh
brutal activities
um and
um as a result everyone died out. Okay.
So no matter how James P. Kahoon
constructed this this experiment
uh ultimately it led to the collapse of
of the rat colony and the extermination
of all the rats.
And he struggled with this all his life
and he could never he could never really
find the answer as to why this was
happening. And the only thing that he
could hypothesize is
maybe water can be infinite. Maybe
security,
food, luxury, maybe all can be provided
infinitely. But one thing that is not
infinite, one thing that is a zero sum
game is the idea of status.
And it's in it's we are ingrained or
sorry it's the desire for status is
inherent to us. We strive for status.
So, normally in the state of nature, um,
rats will fight each other for status.
And the rats who lose, they'll run off
somewhere else and they'll build their
own colony or they'll they get killed by
natural predators. But in an enclosed
environment where the rats can't run off
somewhere else, then they're forced to
constantly fight each other over and
over again for status. Peter Turchin,
the social scientist, has a concept for
this. It's called elite over production.
Societies collapse over time because too
much elite is being produced and
ultimately they will um fight each other
for the limit positions of power and
status.
And so we're living in rat utopia. And
quite quite honestly this is why uh
young people now refuse to have
children. It's not just because the
economic opportunities for young people
uh are very limited. um are very
pessimistic and they are the real reason
is the baby boomer boomers refuse to
give up their status. Think about the
politicians in Washington DC. Um I mean
like um many of them their brains aren't
even functioning and they're still
there. Um and so um we live in a time of
rat utopia. But again, these people are
the ones who gave us birth. They're the
ones who nurtured us, the ones who we
must honor and cherish. So we can never
ever blame the baby boomers for what's
going on. We blame the immigrants or we
blame the Jews or we blame the deep
state or we blame Trump or we blame
Justin Trudeau, but we never blame the
real culprits who are the baby boomers.
Okay. So the question then is what can
we do? And so I think the only thing we
can do is tell the truth. We owe it to
ourselves. We owe it to our children to
let them know the truth. It was not the
immigrants who destroyed the West. It
was not Putin or Trump or Trudeau who
destroyed um the West. It was not the
Jews. It was us because we became
selfish, lazy, and corrupt. That's the
real reason why the west is dying and
the real reason why no one can do
anything about it. Okay? Because we
refuse to omit the truth uh to
ourselves. But the least we can do is
tell the truth to our children. And
that's why I do what I do.
Okay. So, uh again,
apologies for today. I'm sorry. I'm
sorry it's such doom and gloom. Next
week we go back to uh the regular
programming of just cheer. Okay. Um no,
I'm I'm not going to ever be optimistic
about the world because there's no
reason to be optimistic about the world.
Okay. So, next week I'm going to preview
um my the next academic year of classes
I'll be teaching. I'll be teaching three
new classes uh the secret history of of
the world. So I'll be going into the
nexus of finance, intelligence, and
religion. It's going to be a really
interesting class. I'm really looking
forward to to teaching it. I'm really
looking forward to sharing with you.
I'll also be teaching the great books.
I'll also be sharing I'll also be
teaching game theory. Okay. So in my
next video next week, I'm I'll be
sharing with you previewing preview
these three uh classes. Um if you like
what I do, if you please support my work
by uh supporting me on buy me a coffee,
the link is below.
Uh if you want to be part of my
community, the Britive History
community, please join my Discord server
uh this week start um I've started a
Substack and um if if you want to join
my Substack, the link is uh below as
well. So in my substack
um I'll be going into solutions for how
we can rebuild a better world, how we
can work together to build a better
world after the world collapses. Okay.
And uh that's it for today. I'll see you
guys next week. Thank you so much for uh
today and I look forward to next week.